kennen sie dieses handzeichen haben sie
das schon einmal gesehen das ist ein
ganz wichtiges handzeichen dieses
zeichen hat jetzt ein 14 jahre altes
mädchen vor ihrem peiniger gerettet auf
einem spielplatz leider aber zustimmten
dort ist ein schreckliches verbrechen
passiert auf einem spielplatz in
ludwigshafen in rheinland pfalz wurde
ein 14 jähriges mädchen von einem 19
jährigen vergewaltigt aber das mädchen
konnte auf sich aufmerksam machen mit
diesem speziellen handzeichen damit
signalisierte die 14 jährige dass sie in
einer notlage war passanten erkannten
dieses zeichen und der junge mann wurde
festgenommen war bereits
polizeibekannt ja er hatte bereits
mehrere mädchen mit nackt fotos erpresst
auch sein opfer das er jetzt
vergewaltigt hat wir gehen direkt an
diesen spielplatz janine wollbrett
unsere reporterin ist dort vor ort
stellen was kannst du zu diesem
schlimmen vorfall sagen der sich dort
auf diesem spielplatz abgespielt hat ja
das opfer war am letzten wochenende dann
muss der 19-jährige sich herumgetrieben
haben und das mädchen angesprochen haben
sie dann es gibt nichts gezahlt haben
und sich an ihr vergangen haben über den
19 jährigen wissen wir inzwischen dass
er in mannheim geboren ist aber zuletzt
wohnsitzlos war ja und wie du schon
gesagt hast also er hatte schon mehrere
sachen auf dem kerbholz aber laut
staatsanwaltschaft wurde gab es nur eine
einzige verurteilung und zwar wegen
diebstahls und sachbeschädigung
es laufen aber unseres wissens auch in
der mannheimer staatsanwaltschaft ist
ein ermittlungsverfahren anhängig wegen
vergewaltigung und auch in offenburg da
soll er diese unseres wissens zwei junge
mädchen also im internet angesprochen
haben sich nackt fotos geschickt von den
kids geschickt rasen haben und ihnen
dann gedroht haben er möchte weitere
fotos haben sonst wird er die im
internet veröffentlichen
was wissen wir von der zeugen was wissen
wir von den menschen die wert auf dem
spielplatz war und dann aufmerksam
wurden auf das 14 jährige mädchen
ja es ist also so gewesen dass hier gott
sei dank
wir wissen jetzt eine frau vorbeikam die
erst kurz zuvor im internet über dieses
zeichen überhaupt sich aufgeklärt hatte
und nur deshalb weil es praktisch
möglich dass sie der verstanden hat was
das mädchen überhaupt von der will und
dann natürlich die polizei geholt hat
und der täter dann festgenommen werden
konnte da jetzt in der jugendhaftanstalt
in schifferstadt sitzt jetzt sehen wie
du hast auch mit müttern der gesprochen
die dieses handzeichen kennen wir jetzt
eben gerade auch das bild gesehen wir
sehen aber gleichzeitig der spielplatz
hinter dir total leer ist er gesperrt
jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt und kannst du
irgendwelche aussagen darüber treffen
wie viel da los war zu dem zeitpunkt als
der 19-jährige die 14-jährige da ins
gebüsch zerren konnte zeigt uns ein
bisschen diesen ort damit man irgendwie
einschätzen kann wie abgelegen oder eben
belebt dieser ort ist also uns haben
viele passanten gesagt also der
spielplatz ist ja wirklich in der
kleinen siedlung hier und er ist auch
nur bekannt von menschen die hier wohnen
man muss sich das vorstellen das ist
auch nicht einsehbar von der straße muss
so eine kleine stichstraße herein lauf
und dann kommt mir auf diesem spielplatz
wo sich am abend auch viele jugendliche
treffen ja und da muss die 14-jährigen
die unseres wissens auch hier in der
nähe wohnt ist sich immer getroffen
haben mit ihren kumpels mit ihrer clique
weiß man
schwanger das ist auch der spielplatz
ist auch nicht abgesperrt ist es hier
nur so über 30 grad und wenn es kommt
natürlich hat niemand an wir haben aber
ihre mutter gefunden die auch mit uns
gesprochen hat
entschuldigung eine frage noch
entschuldigung gerade einen hinweis von
unserem cvd auf dem or gab deswegen bin
ich sofort ja weiter gemacht mit diesem
gespräch aber eine frage noch kannten
sich täter und opfer gibt es
irgendwelche informationen ob die eine
verbindung zueinander hatten also darf
nur davon ist uns und bislang nichts
bekannt
vielen herzlichen dank dir für diese
informationen dort auf diesem spielplatz
für eine 14 jährige sexuell missbraucht
wurde von einem 19 jährigen
polizeibekannten mann und sich retten
konnte durch dieses zeichen wir zeigen
ihnen das noch einmal denn das ist das
signal wenn sie nach hilfe rufen können
dies aber nicht tun können kamera einmal
auf mich da mich das sein kann sie heben
die hand der daumen geht rein und sie
schließen die hand zu einer faust gott
sei dank hat eine mutter auf diesem
spielplatz dieses signal gesehen konnte
das deuten und so die 14-jährige aus den
fängen des täters befreien
[Musik]